[Music]
it's time to thre equalize people KO
jandro and I we intentionally turned
down screenings even though we got a lot
for this one cuz we were like no we owe
it to the audience who watched equalizer
1 and two with us to watch equalizer 3
with us how you doing Coy I'm so excited
to find out the genre I'm excited too
yeah that's right there was a tonal
shift from one to two but I love both of
them people have really really enjoyed
it did well at the box office so ladies
and gentlemen you know what to do
equalize that like button whatever that
means also uh I wanted to say a really
really really big thank you to everyone
who's been watching our videos first and
foremost as I segue to everyone who's
been purchasing some real reex apparel
one of the absolute best ways to support
the channel we got shirts like this one
right here I call the shop protection
services shirt of course Pedro Pascal
from last of us and baby Yoda we just
launched this Ahsoka stip STI Shir
lightsaber scissors got space babies we
got who influences The influencers
Watchmen inspired got a soda we got a
whole bunch more bottom line it is
easily one of the best ways to support
the channel and plus we put our own
creativity into it ourselves we were
handson with it so thank you guys so
much and lastly full enaction watch
along re single with your own copy of
The Equalizer 3 available for super sex
rejects over at our patreon page we
cover several things exclusively there
with reaction how and watch Longs
included Coy chre you ready so ready I
am so ready to Let's get to
it that's so
pretty wow I wonder what this experience
is like for people who saw equalizer 2
when it first came out then to wait for
this whereas we saw them this year two
months ago yeah cuz I'm like let's pick
it up exactly pretty nice right in yeah
some people waited seven years between
the first and the third one yeah
exactly uh it's a it's a crime guys's
got a pitchfork in him I wouldn't go
that way you got a kid
great reveal shot
yeah oh I love the background use of
hyper
violence that kid is Young
Denzel he would grow up to be Denzel
Washington ooh
cool shutter speed shift damn damn so
the third one's a horror movie
oh wow they they really went right up
close and personal with that one I
wanted us to experience
it these are awesome shots there's a lot
like violence in the background I love
it
oh this is a violent opening they're so
good at making the villains awful in
different ways or is this Denzel's doing
I'll take either one either way violence
I feel like it's too violent for the
protagonist no no I think it's Denzel
he's just lost
it oh I love elegant possible villains
yeah I'm really curious how this
goes still one shot I think so I think
it's still one shot since the threshold
got crossed right like since they
followed behind them that was really
really pretty damn the shadows and
Lighting are on point Who's their gaffer
great
job every step yeah you're right it is
Denzel man that's cool to throw it in
the other person's perspective yeah that
Lighting on
him godamn
right
you to say I know what you
are what you are emphasis you took
something that didn't belong to you I'm
here to take it back even the guy with a
gun hella look so
nervous love other particulate yeah your
man to my left finger on the trigger but
he's a foot Too Close which renders your
man to my right de already he just
doesn't know it yet I feel sorry for his
family man has it missed a step 9
seconds there it is that's what you have
to decide your fate damn it sounds like
jigsaw
now boom boom
[Music]
oh oh oh oh he shot him through his head
he shot him through his
head oh my God the seven-year waight was
worth it I'm so glad we were patient for
seven
years I love these movies so much look
at that shot I know it's
gorgeous holy crap again the Shadows are
on point
beautiful ouch oh right up the exit ouch
it's so fascinating capturing it in this
perspective CU it paints him in almost a
villainous light cuz he's so brutal but
he is like we've seen it yeah but we've
rationalized it oh that music is
great spiderverse
inspired
this one is a violent good time people
woo oh you I think the music works as a
great transition too whatever we're
going next look at the wine spilling
with the blood yeah it's excellent Sony
loves their it's got that like religious
symbolism that just plays all along
this so hyped three
equalize bre in M
now
okay God he's so cool he really is no
whoa whoa
whoa oh no oh my God it threw him off
his game did you see that yeah he just
like that was yeah
just that was not like him that's really
interesting I think he like his Instinct
was the kid was okay and it wasn't oh
dang he actually got clipped
I think he was checking is that what
this movie is about him having to retire
because he's not like on
[Music]
it this what has
existentialism dread dread looms if you
went to the theaters of coin I would be
the exact same thing it'd be everyone
around us you guys shut up
existentialism see
it the lighting is
on
oh
damn holy [__] is he actually going
through
this he's always
Invincible damn this is this is really
punching
he fell onto a bullet oh maybe he
started firing like crazy because he got
shot in the back oh maybe just Panic
yeah that is the
theme always given us a different side
of him every movie giving the movie
purpose justifying
it look he's so emotional this time his
emotions are on the
fences yep they certainly
are oh man that's that's one fen's
reference per equalizer from out of
nowhere I'll pull it off I still haven't
seen
fences I just know his hat it's just as
fun of a reaction oh yeah definitely and
nice drun that's a play watch us watch a
play thank you Andel what's your
name that is not a lie yeah I was
wondering no
h Philadelphia where you supposed to be
oh he said what he said earlier talking
about where you're supposed to be dude
are you the bad guy that is the question
and him not
knowing old man
Robert needs another Cane to equalize
how long I uh three days today you
resurrected like Christ four more
days what a kind man I hope he's
handicapped for this whole movie I think
that would be a really fascinating part
every like movie's been so different he
might be I mean one of the things that
people have often said is that you know
he is a little too Invincible yeah they
did a whole movie where he's mortal and
how he'd see the world not capable of
acting on
it is this about him versing the Mafia
the whole Mafia well it seems like he's
versing like the Italian mafia right cuz
they would be ruling this cuz he's
paranoid every step he's taking yeah
what's he looking out for well that's
interesting
I worry about him taking down the mafia
I don't know if he's in any shape too I
think you can pull it off he's
Unstoppable oh my God I'm Gonna Keep two
for two I'm I got I can do this all day
he's got to come back though slowly he
needs a training day or
[Laughter]
two interesting he where's his wedding
ring on his right
yeah
poison what if this one was just a slice
of Life of him healing Still Still
invested still be invested just watch
him on screen I'm Georg Boni
I'm Jo this is my daughter Gabby oh no
I'm worried for Gio Dr is a very good
doctor he brought me to this world my
parents too almost everybody here
what all them man is very old and
prolific I po your cob behind the
station for when you feel
better I didn't look in your
backs why are they willing to protect
him so much immediately it's cuz he's
American everyone loves Americans oh
they didn't know he was unconscious it's
a friendly Canadian people love
Canadians so much more despair in his
performance yeah I'm really worried for
that kid and all these kind
people cins that's her Vineyard in
Sicily 6.2 miles south of who is this
concerned citizen you were talking to a
Man on Fire just
now canina Arana Vineyards just south of
palmo crates imported from Middle East
Syria by the looks of it fruits tree
nuts spices I'm sorry but there's
nothing unusual about that wine I still
view her as a child actor every time I
see her how is she working at the CIA I
never view her as an adult repackaging
operation by the looks of it you're
going to need a physical access team you
know all this how just passing through
thought it might be of interest to you
people what do you mean you
people so he's going to be like
protecting the people here I assume but
he just put his watch down which is how
he equalizes so is that like him like
I'm I'm off I think he wants to retire
but you can't retire The Man on Fire you
already used that one I just rhyming it
this time all right that's fair somehow
I will working to take you to pelhem
[Laughter]
123 wow this is the shadow movie I love
the lightting so much you just really
get the impression death is waiting for
him it's a really ominous everything
editing tone
[Music]
lighting feels like he's descending the
stairs to heaven what a cool like how
did they that shot s on a lift one day
someone does something unspeakable to
someone else and you do something about
it cuz you can it's who you
are you've always been God it's
flashback this is cool
whoa waa hardcore
[Music]
Henry
interesting oh the reflection man each
one of them gets darker about his view
of himself and everything yeah like the
first an action movie with knowledge of
morality the second when it's like the
ramifications this is like the despair
like the the
weight yeah you really get the to really
throw it into his firsters point of view
completely undoes any glorification of
that moment oh yeah nothing's cool about
murdering a lot of people but the finale
still better be it's going to be awesome
with the watch the watch is going to go
back on you better still bring it F me
[Music]
it this guy is the master at making
friends with people at local shops very
attractive people just love denel I
know on the way
out I feel like there's going to be no
violence for like another another hour
I'm cool man ATT video it's an
interesting structure to to be like
let's throw you into this and now let's
peel it back and deconstruct him long
game the unnerving the bad
elements no violence from him there will
be violence there will be violence
immediate violence looks to be
happening
pay your
[Music]
taxes I don't know there's a lot of
death symbolism man dead fish come
on symbolized
[Music]
life I like this
track this track is cool something's
building yeah son loves the
flare I think fuka really up this game
on the camera work here mhm the lock
offs of POV the like lifts yeah the long
shots too look how tangible this all is
out of the three movies this year set in
Italy this is the prettiest oh
yeah really getting the sense of the
extra and stuff the environment I feel
like I'm here versus me watching here
mhm I suspect action scene it's
looming love how so much of this is
actually an Italian
yeah oh my
god
wow here consequences of not being
obedient to these guys the villainy is
always so horrific in
these the violence feels violent leave
him there for everyone to see yeah we
like we're so desensitized to violence
cuz it's in every movie but like this is
something else that was so brilliant cuz
I I kept wondering why the camera was
locked off to keep him in Focus the guy
in the
wheelchair the weakest and like least
intimidating person it's just a motion
of just watching this vulnerable elderly
man violently murdered there's nothing
about the character you know yeah for
for grilled for
roast yes
well
hello that's
sucker what a great
jab no that I understand I'm
paying
thank oh man I want Enzo as a
friend guy got doesn't have the money
and he's still helping out I love free
stuff oh what are they moving
O's that is that Roy yeah he left the
office he got
promote approximately 11 million us
cameras they all went down at the same
time precisely 1816 is she the daughter
of Melissa Leo that'd be crazy yeah what
do you see when you look at me Denzel
Washington I mean when I come here you
you you you take care me you don't call
ambulance you don't call police why
remember what I asked you you know what
he remembers the
Titans yeah am I a good man or bad man
you asked me and you said you didn't
know only a good man would have said
that or the sociopath who refuses to
acknowledge that he's a bad guy you know
he's our
protagonist our violent violent protag
just saying there's flaws in your
argument there Enzo he's an optimist
Enzo Joker just thought he was ahead of
the
curve but he knew he was a dog chasing
cars while not a religious fella I can
appreciate a movie where they don't shy
away from it if it is very much
interwined and with the film and the
culture and it all makes I agree yeah
makes me think is he going to go to
heaven or hell after death equalizer 4
equalizer 4 Ever him and John Wick both
fighting
underground oh man turning that
beautiful Town into hotels and casinos
is I just love just a silhouette of bad
guys there yeah the lighting's like
we're silhouetted Pure
Evil hasn't been seen reading one book
this movie oh great
call there is some Western Samurai Vibes
to it stranger wandering in a town lone
stranger Good
Samaritan a man
awful
damn how heroing it's like a
[Music]
Inferno how awful this movie is doing an
excellent job at getting you invested in
the community yeah I really care about
everyone even them just saying like
they're good people and now we're like
meeting the good people yeah normally
you rush past that [__] and and like you
said 40 minutes of like gives him time
to heal gives time for us to like really
love and hate these
guys he's got to take out two bosses
which I like he's got to take out the
like debie boss and then
like ch's G to get himself in trouble
I'm worried about him his daughter why
do you do that oh
uh Habit I'm
neat and tell me who cooks for you oh
you
will I would love to show you the real
food of alamonte would you come with me
damn son Hail Mary full of grace
permanent Denzel Riz cannot be stopped
one condition you wear your new
hat it's the Hat it's the Hat it's it's
that hat man that's why they call him
Malcolm X he's got a whole row of them
lining
up rebuild like your
back they see you as one of us now
that's
amazing can't leave protect the people
found life
now the stair seem uplifting but will he
die for his people I think he's about to
I'm still worried he is Jesus as where
this whole trilogy was going leading him
to sacrifice
himself oh hey now turn and face you
straight on if you want to get a better
photograph turn it's not subtle that was
a terrible also real loud you volume on
two
one who are you what were you doing on
that farm in sicy even better a farm
that bundles methamphetamine based
narcotics told you on the phone just a
guy best passing I love he just
addresses at head on in every movie like
I'm this guy how did you know I was me
you're reading a tour guide for Rome
were in alante and your voice the way
you pronounce your M it's a dry
sandpapery sound nice that's compliment
you kill him I look like a guy who kills
people warming to the possibility to
[__] like like it or not you're a person
of interest I'm an interesting
person not even a little curious how I
found you took the same fairy Crossing
you noticed the security cameras on the
terminal building you rewind two weeks
saw the license plates for the VW
damn you'll uh do a deep search on the
name already in the works oh good good
good she raise your antenna I think it's
I think she's the daughter I think she's
the daughter when you said it you're
like that's
perfect [__] you oh no cuz the
van a [__] Gio shouldn't be poking your
Italian nose in the places they don't
belong he's being a cop a good one not
in that
town whoa great shot damn that so
cool
oh no please tell me it's just a
taunting session
yeah oh that is really icky oh
god oh my
god dude don't be
loud
dude
[Music]
[Applause]
dude a that's so sad we care about
everyone now like supporting characters
the town in general this is the first
one in the trilogy that makes me go what
would I do in this position yeah they've
humanized him to such a level and even
for this geog guy you know I was like
right there going like man what would I
do in this position it's the camora the
andang what you call mafia they like
cancer more cure he's the Cure he's
going to be the surgeon of the
town I think he takes out everybody
except the big bad and the big bad and
them take each other out the way how
John Q needed a
doctor he's going to be the doctor for
this
city di to search go apparently you're a
ghost o
not afraid of ghosts black shirt white
wall black shirt white jacket that
Sicilian Farmers Lorenzo vital ran a
massive cyber Empire siphoning money
from offshore accounts government
agencies Pension funds so I'm off the
hook for now I got a idea cell we didn't
know existed feel like she's into him or
something everyone is she delivers her
lines like Lil in the way she blinks and
everything be dealing with the locals
now they have their own agendas what
they say is not always what they mean
aren't you you just full of
tips ah but you want to see that tip you
know what I
mean why smuggle drugs into the most
secure port in the entire region I'll
Circle back to you with the answer when
I'm done then you can answer my question
why me cuz you're the daughter of the
dead woman from the previous movie
you're cast very similarly I do believe
that's
true restaurants sit down you know it's
a classic equalizer moment oh sit across
from
him that's right you make IC cont that's
what I'm talking about go over there
bring your loud mouth over there yeah
you like being on another little
people's business trying very hard not
to be but you make it very challenging
for me
everything in life is about timing now
unfortunately for you yours isn't very
good I'm starting to believe from the
bottom of my heart that this is where
I'm supposed to
be that you and your friends do please
do it somewhere else you warning me I'm
preparing
[Laughter]
you
is that a TX
no oh yes let's go right
there that's the median nerve that I'm
compressing oh my God I love when they
educate scale from 1 to 10 that's a
two that's a
three I go to four your [__] on yourself
you don't want that I don't want that
they don't want
that tell your comp that they can leave
beat oh my God he
is one little maneuver take the gun out
of your waist put it on the
table he had the opportunity to shoot
him and he still cannot focus his
brain's just Desiring he could have
easily shot got him right
there and the game is a foot yes and the
first action we've seen is a finger
between
nerves little brother
syndrome all right take out these guys
oh damn oh God good stun Fork holy crap
Wow real a real person there that' be a
dummy and it was such good editing when
they subbed it in woo well he's taking
out two of your guys wow that was
intense go for the Viking get the big
one
yes Viking with
wine yeah you got
this oh my God he's having
ooh ooh
ooh
oh look at the lighting the lighting is
so good oh [__]
that's
damn there's call backs to the first one
in this one oh I have chills that was
amazing and the Halo oh the Halo
yeah he was waiting for that he was cre
he was
G going down oh man yeah there's a
villain side here oh it's so
dark is anyone going to snitch on the
what went down at the restaurant M and
he obviously
knows oh my God the F9 movie was
happening Jason Mamoa did this I'm Dante
on Shante why sis why not Ela Sardinia
makes no sense Frank running drugs
through the most secure port in the
region the mainland faction took
possession and Naples it's easiest port
to slip things through now I got to say
I I generally like Dakota Fanning but
I'm I'm not finding her very believable
in this movie I don't think she's a CIA
agent and I do like her I don't know
what it is there's something about her
line deliveries that's it's interesting
because it doesn't quite play it's not
reading genuine to me I feel like she's
acting and I think since everyone else
is so natural it's making it stand out a
bit yeah you can't Coast by and your Man
on Fire to Goodwill like to question
these
men you son of a [__] so that's your
one you can't
interview now she knows where to start
so what's the deal I'm not here to
negotiate I'm here to give you an
opportunity for what I need some
information and you're going to give it
to
me
well he just gave up the information
she's very intimidating Fanning but I
feel like I'd be terrified if I was part
of this
family okay didn't look armed
but died like Elvis how' they know to
shoot that guy in the in the bathroom he
was armed they but how' they know there
was a guy in bathroom was AR they must
have hurt I don't pooping sound of
pooping I'm pretty sure she's a child
someone's clearly telling her
things dude
you're going to get yourself
killed yeah what is your what is your
dumb ass you're by
yourself there his
finger oh his whole
hand all right so still attached I guess
that was
extreme oh oh my
God the ice bucket what kind of knife is
that that I don't know it's infomercial
and cut through
pennies it was just like a clean little
sweep right there man worries boat goes
through Stak and hands like nothing
Chief barell is being attacked by who we
don't know but he has information
regarding your investigation this
officer will escort you to the hospital
no excuse me probably makes Chief Morell
look non-corrupt he definitely isn't
Under Suspicion now it's not terrorist
it's theora careful let me call you back
in a minute do not start your car we've
learned
oh if he hadn't
called
Damn classic that explosion was
crazy oh oh my God this is a real
horrifying
aftermath I'm used to starting car
explosions but just moving along but
damn this is a this is real
wow oh now it's
personal oh no this is a dangerous place
for her to
be we're not looking for Terror it's
theora I would have trust a single
person him those doctors
[Music]
nobody all because he looked up a
van
you mess with one of us you mess with
all of
us oh my God whoa is Denzel above them
oh no my God
what land
him a that dude's definitely def in that
ear now yeah I mean whatever ear is
left oh my God is
Roberto coming out into the open I
killed your brother you're a Long Way
from Home
American moer I'm where I'm supposed to
be here I
am you do do I understand weakness I
understand pain I understand death I
understand suffering and because of
these people I'm starting to understand
peace you can't take that away from me
woo
[__] you can take anything you want take
me here I am just don't do it here this
is the best place American so these
people can see and tell others what they
witness oh it's your choice it's always
my
[Music]
choice zero in what is
happen Eno
Enzo oh my God they're all
recording oh yeah what a beautiful
moment but it won't last long cuz I'll
be back I'll be here I'll leave this
place like a war blew through it I'll be
waiting for you hurry
up bad ass yeah oh he got the watch back
he got the watch back now it's real uh
that's his main
accessory
he went to
them Shadows can't get over it these
guys are out of
[Laughter]
time
oh
[Music]
look oh yo he is cleaning
house
[Music]
oh my God I have become
death oh oh he just solved the just
already took care big bad's
done oh oh never mind like them we're
just racist against Italians yeah go
teed Italians look alike then dark
[Laughter]
lighting
die I like how not flashy this one is
like it's brutal and just
G I like the oh god oh wow the weight of
sin just like cast over this whole thing
yeah movie is stayed
ominous whoa awesome
whoa brought the hanging
back you want some scared and suffering
before ouch ouch ouch ouch oh my God
it's home alone all over
again ouch oh I don't like it I don't
like it that's the problem the whole
rest of violence stepping on glass I
relate to I've lived through that
part man the camera work in this is
really great knowing where to place it
and how to handle reveals how this like
and how it's also mirroring the
beginning of the film you're going
through the perspective of the villain
but now it's all forground violence the
beginning was background violence cuz
we've leveled up to like the
tension
oh you are sick Robert yeah that guy's
got
issues like yeah put a back together for
a
[Music]
reveal don't with
me there you go got what you asked
for who are you damn you have less than
six minutes P the pills
backyard give him a chance to come kill
him one day when
I is he a good guy or a bad
guy he's Dexter Morgan he's like
stalking this Dy man around his house I
mean he deserves it but it's
horrifying oh my God is he going to put
him on the spikes he's going to be so
gross isn't he yeah how's he going to
what's the fat
[Laughter]
[Music]
wow does he March him into the center of
the
square oh
damn the [__]
Godfather so tragic oh my God he's just
like watching him die this is crazy time
he's like guiding him to like wherever
he wants him watching him die
[Music]
slowly what ceremony is this so
beautiful
sin the first Apple Robert's also a
thief did cleaned up the town bur local
he definitely wasted those Peppers
too is that your go bag
$366,500
wow so what's it for it's Greg D's
pension he's a brick layer his Union's
pension fund got hacked nine months ago
okay so you tracked down some guy's life
savings to a cyber ghost that no one has
been able to find for years it happens
to be a drug smuggling Way Station I
didn't know that until I got in
there is this guy some friend of yours
no gave him my LIF once ah great what's
this it's your pension how did you was
me why something like this for a
stranger I guess he is a good guy
equalizes he just does it yeah it's
balances the scill someone left this for
you at the front desk got a meeting with
the director in 30 minutes he wants to
meet the person who broke up in the
Italian situation nicely done he was a
good guy I was worried yeah is that Mom
look look at the just God damn it your
mother would be proud of you
yeah I think I saw a portrait look at
your
portrait black book oh he's giv her all
of
[Music]
his yes
confirmed oh so she's going to carry on
the franchise she's going to be The
Equalizer
now hope she learns how to fight hope
she learns how to murder hope she learns
how to do all the things cuz so far she
got a lot of help we won
I this is our town serial
killer all right I'm moving to Italy
been a pleasure
[Applause]
America and
zo
a so in the beginning he saw death
because he wanted peace but now he's
found peace so he doesn't need to die
and he's accepted that he's the Grim
Reaper
himself I have become death destroyer of
Italian mafia for time oh man wow what a
film man that was great that was great
wow W one of the best shot action movies
I've ever seen w wow wow wow wow wow wow
wow ladies and gentlemen if you're
listening to this on Apple Spotify rate
it
we have just watched equalizer 3
literally moments ago when we're going
to talk about it with equalizing
efficiency still think they should have
called the three equalizer I feel like
that title would have helped serve the
mood of this you know the box office
would have tripled had it thre equalized
absolutely what alrighty man Coy please
please um what did you think we'll do
quick category breakdowns denzo
Washington's performance uh I think that
this is a contender for greatest sequel
uh and Trilogy in all of action largely
because of the weight that Denzel brings
to everything like this could been I
don't think it would have gotten a
sequel much less a threequel if it
hadn't been for his gravitas his ability
to make everything feel so important the
ability to have us judge him but not in
a judgmental way to assess him we were
always scrutinizing and feeling the
weight of his actions and the POV shots
and the the Judgment he was putting on
himself but you always wanted to see him
as good and characters like Punisher
characters like you know Vigilantes to
the scale are always tricky because it's
so easy to go like oh violence is fine
they don't make violence fine at any
point but it's his performance that
allows you to feel like yeah is it
Justified and you question yourself but
if if the performance wasn't a 10 then
you wouldn't be able to yeah I thought
he was excellent I mean every single
movie we've gotten a different a
different more intimate look at him
because the first one he he is more kept
that at a distance from us he's more
mysterious and he's just more like a
badass act yeah he's just doing awesome
stuff yeah he's just a great guy in that
one and and you want him to become the
action hero and the second one does
become more reflective more intimate uh
more
introspective and this one carries that
on from looking at him in in a way of of
a like I think it's brilliant it's not
just a cool action movie Motif which I
thought that's maybe what they might
have been doing and then but you quickly
pick up on that they're not just doing
this for cool int reintroduction into
equalizer 3 of starting it off with the
villain's perspective of him witnessing
the vi like the it's the villain being
like this is a [__] yeah this is
violent situation
we what is what is do this who could do
this what what is capable of doing
something this horrific and this brutal
and by himself MH and then to strip him
down where he is handicapped forcing him
into a position to slow down and take it
all in and to reflect like he's
physically forced to reflect upon the
the situation and and then to have the
religious angles of course of the weight
of sin C that is you know um Weighing on
him throughout this entire experience
and I I love it because it is very
philosophical it is very existential but
a lot of it is just performance and
mood-based well it's not exactly the
like they don't go like too overt about
it other than like the visual references
yeah I think the ominous tone is is so
many different pieces it's the sound
design it's the the cinematography we
talked about a ton because it is
stunning this might be the prettiest
action movie silhouette movie so shadowy
and black and white there's so much
black and white like it's a movie about
good or bad black and white and they
frame it like that they're like what if
this is here and this is here and then
the beginning being violent in the
background and then as we escalate into
accepting his violence the violence is
in the foreground and whether or not we
we feel justified in the violence that
he has now chosen to take cuz it's in
front of us instead of behind us and I
thought that was a really interesting
choice it was it was really interesting
because it's it's this community that
he's a part of that does need him and
they don't judge him like they accept
him pretty early on and they let him be
a part they just let him be part of it
and he does this like really violent
acts but no one everyone's like but he's
helping us he's helping us and at the
end of the day we need him you know and
you could still see his hearts in the
right place and I appreciate for an act
for a movie for a franchise that starts
off as just straight up like wikian it's
such it's such an action movie The First
movie is such an action movie and it
this had the capacity to potentially
become pretentious you know o of like I
an art house action I get what you're
trying to do but come on like you know
what if the allegory for Jesus yeah it
could have been easily but it didn't
ever go there and here they really stuck
to what they wanted to do of by the time
they get to the finale it it actually
does not succumb to like it's cool by
appreciation and observation but it does
not ultim isn't cool like the death of
that guy is hard to watch they don't
dissolve in into just oh like well we
were joking that it would do which I
really thought they were going to do I
was kind of afraid for a couple minutes
I like you you kind of get that cool
catharsis moment when he does kill crazy
unhinged brother yeah yeah but it's
still unsettling and unnerving because
he's chewing it up he's enjoying it he's
delighting in the violence and that was
so smart to have the two bosses so you
could get the action to satisfy that but
also be uncomfortable with that action
and then even more uncomfortable with
the Slow Burn walk death yeah it's like
he does become death by the end of this
film uh he he is accepting of that you
know and that's his piece that is his
piece it's it is strange but for for a
peculiar odd
character uh is something that is larger
than life uh I think it works for the
world somehow works like yeah I mean is
it is it acceptable in Real Life Society
probably not but in a world like this
yeah [__] it I'll get on board for it
why not and I love that they leaned into
the isolation in the beginning and like
him discovering and slowing down because
of his injuries so that almost made me
think like what if he had had to slow
down at any point in his life would he
have found peace sooner could he have
and then there's all the talk of like
I'm right where I should be there's all
this talk of like this is the distance
between this and this this is the timing
of this and this and that's the the when
he could have slowed down so I love that
they kind of wrap up multiple subplots
in one ending with this is where he's
meant to be this is the only time this
could have happened this is the only way
this could have happened and and it just
beautifully tells a mafia Story I mean
it's called equalizer and I've always
thought that was such a funny title for
what it is for what it is yeah and and
to me he does in a lot of ways become
The Equalizer by the end of this film of
yes he is the embodiment of Darkness but
he's doing it for good and they don't
shy away from him being the embodiment
of Darkness nor do they glorify it it
was surprising how they how they managed
to like yeah we got to frame it cool
it's going to look cool but you're not
going to feel like it's cool you know
when you're watching it it's the
anti-walmart movie you like you know all
those Walmart movies that are like $5
bin like look at all this violence blood
and awesome this is like well that's
cool looking but why do I feel bad about
it like it doesn't feel like the
glorification of action movies it's it's
almost a drama using action to make it
more dramatic like the action serves the
drama more than the drama serves the
action it is one of those things where I
do feel like the experience of
performance and director really go hand
inand because they haven't shifted
director you know they start working
together on training day and they
haven't shifted director since the start
of this franchise and you could feel the
evolution of them understanding that a
lot of the character of of Robert McCall
is experienced more tonal wise more more
visual wise it's it's it's all the
unspoken stuff and while there some
stuff obviously spoken where they like
they they mainly speak the themes is
what they speak you know but the
character growth and the trajectory a
lot like they're not saying a lot of
things that were saying but it's there
it's very much it's very much on screen
and I I love that fuka I I feel like his
it's like The Equalizer ones are pretty
much near perfect first installment
movie but as these films have gotten
heftier as these films have gotten
deeper uh I appreciate the maturity of
them and the will the boldness to go
that way because this to me
is I could see it not being audience
satisfactory but I I haven't heard
people be disappointed with no I mean
it's got like you know four and a half
stars or whatever and and the IMDb is a
little low it's like .1 which I don't
like but uh I love that it did well box
office cuz I'd love to see things like
this get rewarded cuz it didn't cost
that much like you know this movie is
not that expensive compared to the
Blockbusters or even like you know High
budget dramas out there so to make more
things like this where it's like
resonating with audiences enough to make
a profit trust the audience like this
did but we didn't get the there was some
stuff I wish we got we didn't get the
cool I'm to just count my watch and
we're going to he didn't need it anymore
we're going to do some of those cool
visuals need it anymore any zip around
evolved Sherlock holes now it's slow
Framing and now it's using foreground
and background now it's pacing I did
like the POV of like this it it's cool
because the first movie is you're
observing and wondering questioning who
this person is and this movie takes so
much to the point of putting you into
his that you actually go into his own
POV at one point and you're like oh yeah
observing him do cool violence is one
thing but when you're in it through his
perspective it is like this is a reflect
experience you're thinking like what
would it be like to cause this harm and
like could I inflict this pain I
couldn't I think the movie in terms of
some of the the the weaker side which
something that the other ones kind of
fall under the same camp is
uh kind I mean I love the sense of
community that we got here because
that's where R mallic sells at is
getting involved with some kind of
community whether it be a warehouse of
his co-workers or a whole friendly Town
Boston Boston or as a lift driver or the
city of Italy he's a man of the Town
yeah he's it I I love that Community
Vibe I love the whole sense there um
because I really did care about everyone
and and like even like a character like
the geoc cop who I'm like I don't really
know this guy but man I really don't
want him to die yeah uh I really love
that Enzo another one like this is
immediately captivated by this guy but
the the I did find some of the CIA
investigating stuff a tad boring there
was about five minutes that I was like
was this filmed in a post screen it for
the fans they want to know where this
plot Point came from because a lot of it
felt like re-shoot or or additional
photography like the entire scene of
like her interrogating that guy she's
not intimidating how did she get that
out of him like she literally said like
I've got nothing for you okay here it is
yeah I mean a lot of the actual CIA
stuff that you would cut to I didn't
find all that interesting I thought it
was just like plot [__] like let's just
get information out there like we've
been with him for too long in Rome let's
go over here yeah there was a lack of
panach
the Italian mobster guys what I loved
about them was when they would um when
you would get some of their weird like
uh idiosyncracies that not not weird for
them but that's part of the caption that
c like when they're just eating
spaghetti and talking about what they're
going to do yeah and it just feels so
casual about it I like that again though
like I I do this this one is not really
affected by because it's so much about
Robert McCall's Journey that you're not
it's so much about witnessing like he is
just he is becoming fully accepting of
of what he is MH uh because because in
the beginning he is like thinking of
just I might just off myself you know
find peace that way and instead he just
finds a way to live as death instead of
giving into death it's I mean we're all
seeking peace so it's really interesting
that that's the answer for him and it
made me go like what would the answer
for the average person or maybe but the
the there was something still about the
about checking in with the with the
villains that like yeah when they were
doing violent [__] I I was really
compelled by it and you do like hate
them for it but plot wise they weren't
really the the first two had second this
that's secondary for me I feel like the
CIA stuff was really like a times very
dull and then the villain wise unless
they were doing some actually violent
they weren't that interesting sure I
think the villains in the first two were
definitely more captivating but I kind
of like that the villain in this one was
at times Denzel yes yeah so that that
made it you know what I mean like that
balanced that equalized the scales for
for the villain being a little weaker
there was uh you know it equalized my oh
I could have used more of that but I
didn't want more of that because how
much I was with him I thought this was
excellent man I thought it was excellent
overall and like these other things were
were so even compared to like the
runtime they they were featured in the
film very limited yeah I I do think um
dakot of Fanning
was like properly cast in theory yeah
because you get an A Very incredible
actress generally you get someone that
looks like Melissa Leo and you have
someone the right age it all works and
then like and you get the fan service of
hey fire it didn't work though it worked
on paper and and I like her normally I
just didn't I I couldn't believe her for
someon I don't know if it's baby face I
don't know if it's line delivery I don't
know if it's the combination of everyone
else being in like really really
grounded and she felt like she was
performing there was enough elements I
was like I yeah it it felt like I I felt
all her choices sure you know and and
not in a not in a way that I felt lived
in that's fair everyone else felt very
lived in yeah even Roy yeah I could feel
like tired of being C I think you're
trying to play CIA vers but I don't
believe you and that's hard cuz that's
such a tricky role to be like spouting
Exposition also this person over here
this like it's not an easy role but
it's very predictable TST yeah it took
like five minutes to be like I feel like
to tell you what this person is right it
was a little too obvious and they were
trying to make it like a big thing and
then they yeah they didn't show the the
frame until that you would like even
called how they're going to reveal like
no you're not
yeah but man 90% of this movie yeah most
of it though great and in terms of like
focusing on dead I I I personally would
still rank two as my favorite I think uh
one and two are tied and this is a step
down because one and two would just be
by my mood if I wanted to have a drama
I'd still watch two over this I wanted
have an action I'd still watch one over
two but I think this is still on par
overall because I can't think of many
trilogies that are this good yeah no I
mean I I still think it it is like a
necessary part of the viewing experience
and I I'm I I overall I love it yeah
overall I do I you know it's the problem
when you rank three and you put one as
you put one of them as three it sounds
like you don't like it no no I'm just
I'm just acknowledging my mood would
determine what I watch but this would
still be the one I'd probably watch last
doesn't make this one lesser I agree
it's just like those are so incredible
but as a Trilogy like I think this is
overall better than the John Wick 1
through three uh cuz three dropped off
for me a little bit with John Wick and I
think uh I don't even know what else
would be like this category certainly
not the Takens like this this is you
know I mean like Takens are just like
violence is good no uh I think this is
one of the better action trilogies they
often compare Robert M like who win
Robert mccole or John wi I hear that
conversation brought up a lot but I'm
like but in terms of a movie they're so
different they're so different they're
so like I think I think you can kind of
see some similarities between John Wick
one and equalizer one but as a franchise
they're wildly different is is John Wick
is like a mythical fantasy world yeah
John Wick's like what's the coolest
stunt we could do this is like how
violent can we make you uncomfortably
watch something and this one's like
let's just zero in our Robert McCall the
more we go you know yeah but I I do
think as trilogies go like this is up
there for me this is I think it's a
solid ass Trilogy um yeah especially for
an action Trilogy it was hard to wait
not see this in theaters I'm so glad we
did though like this was one that I was
like I kept seeing like I'd be an AMC
and be like ah like then this was so
good this is great this is great all
right guys what did you think about the
equalizer 3 where would you rank it um
in terms of the which where you would
place it on the TR I don't know why I
could have just slowed down instead that
you know what I'm trying to say out of
the three where would you rank it uh
leave a like on this video check us out
on patreon also where support the
channel check out one of our shirts I'm
wearing one all the time as should you
and we will catch you all on the
flippity flip peace out reack
[Music]
Nation